yeah but when you take a stance publicly
you put yourself in danger i think
physically
do you not think about that yeah no i um
yeah i mean i get afraid of murderers a
little bit but i
but it's funny like i i've a few times
a couple of times
um the uh
fbi or whatever i said like we have
someone who we have someone in our
custody who um the one was uh a guy that
i was on his like kill list that they
caught with like bombs and stuff and
then another was a guy that
they they they arrested him and he had a
backpack that just had two of my
stand-up dvds in it and a picture of
himself in like full jihad
um
get up uh yeah wardrobe and gun and
everything and and then they have to let
you know
but they can't give you details so they
go we legally have to let you know
and then they give you no details and
they just say you know uh you should
hire um bodyguards and definitely change
your routine i was like i'm not a
bodyguard level
you know really occasionally but you are
because you're a human being both times
i was like about to go on the road so it
like i ended up like almost breaking
even because i had to pay for security
and so that's why she got married
with no teeth i do actually do this
but does that not scare the [ __ ] out of
you it's funny because the the um guy
with the bombs
i called sasha baron cohen who's like my
brother and he goes through this a lot
and stuff and he goes
you know
sis uh no one really ever dies from male
bombs
yeah i guess that's true
what's two or three less fingers
fingers i mean when you really think
about it no one dies from male bombs but
yeah i mean i i definitely have been
told to like change my routine and i try
to be
i have like a
[Music]
my house that i live in is under a
completely different name under it that
has nothing to do with me and i use a
different you know people
i just but how do you sleep
i it never seems in the moment it never
seems like re but this is a funny
conversation we've had which is
so you know she has his house and she
has this alarm system that's very secure
and then when i started i feel very safe
like it was yeah but then when i stay
over
she goes well i don't i don't put on the
alarm when you're here i never do it i'm
like but then are you scared i'm gonna
die in other words because in that
scenario i'm fighting a murderer and
she's running to safety and i'm like
what about the scenario why are you why
is that the scenario in your head why
aren't i fighting the murders we've
discussed it i'm fighting the murder
it's a conversation we've had so
i just so my thought is if she puts the
alarm on then no one has to fight the
murder and then we're both fine but for
some reason you know when i'm there it's
like that i feel safe
no i'll turn it on but then we can't
open the doors we have to remember
because i'm so afr i'm like chicken
little
so i i'm so afraid to trigger the alarm
because i'll have a heart attack at the
noise yeah yeah you know you're more
scared of the alarm than intruders yeah
that i'm yeah
maybe we don't know something about are
you do you have any special
like uh
no i mean i i you know she's a black
belt my daughter do this really yeah you
want me to come over
you can hire me for security great i do
think well my theory is that mary will
protect us because i know that if
murderers come over mary yeah or dog no
i see the
this is how i feel though if murderers
come over she'll definitely instantly go
on her back to get her belly rubbed and
then they'll rub her belly and they'll
be like no wow what are we doing
yeah
i sought it out i didn't realize
or she'll do what she does to her
shrinks but she'll start talking and
then they'll just kill themselves oh my
gosh rory
[Music]